Hi everyone, this is Jerry.
And this is a game analysis between Donald
Byrne and Bobby Fischer.
It was played in New York City on October
17th, 1956.
At the time Fischer was thirteen years old.
And soon after this game it was given the
title "Game of the Century".
Rating and commenting are appreciated.
And any questions you have for me feel free
to send one my way.
Hope you enjoy the game.
Byrne opens the game with the move knight
to f3, development.
Fischer opens up with knight to f6, development.
Pawn to c4, a move directed at controlling
a central square, d5.
Pawn to g6, making way to fianchetto the king
bishop to g7.
Knight to c3, development.
Bishop to g7, development and making way to
castle.
Pawn to d4, establishing a pawn in the center,
and making way for the queen bishop to develop.
Castle, a developing move getting the king
safe.
Bishop f4, development.
Pawn to d5 signaling the Grunfeld Defense,
placing a pawn in the center and also striking
at c4.
Queen to b3, indirectly attacking d5.
Pawn captures pawn, queen captures pawn, and
now both the queen and bishop are directed
at c7.
Fischer follows up with pawn to c6.
If we just take a look back, it's worth noting
that if Fischer were to play pawn to c6 now,
white could continue pawn to e3, and now if
pawn takes pawn, the bishop has the option
of taking on c4 developing a new piece, and
then getting ready to castle.
However, by capturing on c4 right now in this
position black does not give white the possibility
of taking on c4 with the bishop because the
pawn is still on e2.
So as is often the case in chess, move order
matters, and this position right here is no
exception.
So after queen captures pawn... how to meet
this threat?
You might be thinking, well why not develop
a piece and prevent this capture from occurring
on c7?
Well that might run into trouble with a move
like pawn to d5.
The knight is shooed away from c6, and then
the pawn can be taken on c7.
So that's why we see pawn to c6 here.
Pawn to e4 is the continuation establishing
yet another pawn in the center, and making
way for the king bishop's development.
Knight to d7, getting ready to come to b6
where it would be attacking the queen.
It temporarily obstructs the queen bishop's
development.
An alternative would be knight to a6, staying
out of the bishop's way, and preparing a pawn
to c5 advance where that pawn would strike
at d4.
But instead we see the knight coming to d7.
And now rook to d1, placing the rook opposite
the queen.
Black has to be a bit careful.
Whenever a rook is opposite your own queen,
you have to be careful of tactics.
Knight to b6, attacking the queen and allowing
the bishop to come out.
Queen to c5, a bit awkward.
Maybe better is queen to b3.
Although maybe Byrne was turned off to this
move as a result of a developing moved to
e6 where the bishop is now attacking the queen.
Fischer is able to take advantage of this
queen's placement shortly.
Fischer follows up with bishop to g4, pinning
the knight to the rook.
And now Byrne plays bishop to g5, violating
one of the well-known principles in chess
which states: "you should not move the same
piece more than once in the opening".
And this bishop initially came to f4, and
now it's going to g5.
This is not to be recommended especially in
this position.
Fischer is now able to execute a series of
exceptional moves, and it starts with knight
to a4 deflecting the c3 knight from the defense
of the e4 pawn.
The move that was played in the actual game
was queen to a3.
However it's worth taking a look at what would
occur if knight takes knight.
This is what would happen: knight takes pawn,
forking the queen and bishop.
If queen takes pawn, that will result in queen
takes queen, bishop takes queen, rook to e8...
after the bishop moves, the knight can come
here, discovered check on the king and the
knight is going to be picked off, or maybe
even the rook.
An alternative is bishop takes pawn... that
will result in knight takes queen, bishop
takes queen, knight takes knight, black is
doing better in this position as well getting
ready to take the bishop...pawn.
Another choice after knight takes pawn is
queen to c1.
That'll result in queen to a5, checking the
king, hitting the knight, hitting the bishop.
If knight blocks, bishop takes knight, pawn
takes bishop, knight takes bishop.
The queen can't take the knight because it's
protected.
And one other choice is to block with the
bishop will result in knight takes bishop,
queen takes knight, queen takes knight.
Black is doing better in this variation as
well.
One more choice after knight takes here is
queen to b4.
That's going to result in knight takes bishop,
knight takes knight, bishop takes rook, king
takes bishop, bishop takes pawn.
And there is a nasty discovered check that's
in the air after the bishop moves.
Black is doing better here as well.
So the move that actually did get played was
queen to a3.
And now we see knight takes knight.
If queen takes knight, just knight takes pawn
forking the queen and bishop.
So pawn takes knight was played, and now knight
still takes on e4, and allows this fork, bishop
captures pawn on e7.
The rook and queen are attacked.
Fischer follows up with queen to b6.
If bishop takes rook, that'll result in bishop
take bishop.
The queen is getting hit.
If queen to b3, knight takes c3.
If queen takes knight, the bishop is going
to win the queen because there's a pin.
If queen takes queen, pawn takes queen.
The rook is still hit.
The rook and knight are both converging on
a2.
And even though the queens are off the board,
the white king is still in trouble.
If rook to a1, rook to e8.
King here, knight check.
The f2 pawn will fall, and the white king
is going to have a giant headache to deal
with because these bishops are going to give
him problems.
So in this position the bishop did not take
the rook.
Instead Byrne chose to develop the bishop
to c4.
And now we see knight takes c3.
If queen takes knight it's just rook comes
here, pins the bishop and the bishop will
eventually be won.
And so the move that was played is bishop
to c5 attacking the queen.
Rook on f to e8.
It's important that it's this rook that comes
to e8 because there are continuations where
this a8 rook will function well on the a-file,
as is the case in the actual game.
King to f1.
And now the move that caught everyones attention,
bishop to e6!!
Ignoring the threat on your own queen and
instead attacking the bishop.
One continuation from here is to take the
knight.
If that did occur, queen captures bishop would
be played seeing how there's a pin against
the queen.
If pawn takes queen, bishop takes queen.
From this position, if bishop takes bishop
that'll lead to a checkmate in six.
If you'd like to, pause the video and see
if you can figure it out.
It's a checkmate in six problem.
Okay, the solution starts out with queen to
b5 check.
Bishop blocks, queen captures bishop, king
to g1, knight to e2 check, king to f1, knight
to g3 that's double check...in double check
the king must always move, king to g1, queen
to f1 check, rook captures queen the only
move, and now knight to e2 and that's mate...smothered
mate.
So the only other choice from here is to just
take the queen, and that's what Byrne played
in the actual game.
And that ends up putting white in a lot of
hot water.
Bishop captures bishop checking the king.
King to g1, knight e2, king f1, knight captures
pawn discovered check.
If the rook blocks the check, that'll result
in pawn takes bishop.
The only way to now move the queen from the
rook's attack is to play to c3, and defend
the rook.
That'll result in knight captures knight,
the bishop is hitting the queen.
After queen captures bishop, rook to e1 and
that's mate.
So that's why rook here is no good.
So white unfortunately has to go back to g1.
Knight gives another check, another check
discovered, and the knight is hitting the
rook.
King back to g1, and now pawn captures bishop,
the queen is being attacked by the rook.
Queen to b4 attacking the bishop.
Black first meets that threat with rook to
a4, attacking the queen, and defending the
bishop.
And after queen captures pawn, only now does
black take the rook.
And now it's just a matter of winning the
game from this point on.
Pawn to h2 getting ready to sneak the king
out and then get the rook involved, but it's
too little too late.
Rook captures pawn, king to h2, knight captures
pawn attacking the rook.
Rook to e1, rook captures rook, and white
throws a check in first so that the bishop
has to work himself into a pin, bishop f8.
And knight captures rook, and now we see bishop
to d5.
From this point on, black just organizes all
of his pieces and gets it to a point where
they are coordinated.
And as a result the white queen will not be
able to attack anything of black's.
So knight to f3, knight to e4, queen to b8
attacking b7, pawn to b5.
Pawn to h4 getting ready to come to h5 and
maybe smash up the kingside structure.
But Fischer just stops that right away, pawn
to h5.
Knight to e5 getting ready to come to d7 where
it would be attacking the pinned piece.
So Fischer just gets out of the pin, king
to g7.
And if you just take into account this position
right here, everything is protected of black's.
The king guards the pawn, the bishop, these
pawns are protected, these pawns are protected,
and this bishop here guards both the f7 pawn,
the c6 pawn, the knight, and the rook.
Everything is strung together and as a result
the white queen can do nothing.
King to g1, and now it's just a matter of
mating the white king.
And it turns out in the following way: bishop
to c5 check, king to f1, knight g3 check,
king to e1...these are all only moves, bishop
check, king to d1, bishop check, king to c1...the
king is getting walked all the way along the
first rank, knight check, king to b1, knight
c3 check, king to c1, rook to c2 and that's
mate.
So that's all for this video.
Hope you got something out of it.
Take care, bye.